Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of Holotalk.
And this is a special broadcast because I'm here in Staten Island and I'm visiting with John Ivini, who many of you may recognize as the author of homemade holograms and numerous, numerous scientific projects that uh he has undertaken over the years.
How are you today, John?
I'm great.
How are you doing, Frank?
Doing good.
I see we have a copy of your book here.
Uh I've had this book for ages.
This is a first uh edition.
I'm hoping to get you to sign it for me so I can take it back to my own house.
Uh you I told me a little bit earlier an interesting story about uh you getting involved with holography and how the book came about.
Maybe you could uh if you don't mind saying that story over again for the listeners that are listening around the world to you right now.
All right.
Well, how I started in holography was um I knew everything about the theory of holography, and I knew about reference beams, and uh I also realized from my reading that if any objects moved by half a wavelength of light, we would no longer get a hologram.
So when I knew had all this theoretical knowledge, I didn't think it was practical for anybody in uh home-based to actually produce a hologram.
So as time went on, I found out about a woman, Linda Lore, who was giving workshops in Long Island, and giving workshops and making holography.
So I contacted Linda, called her up, joined the workshop, traveled all the way out on Long Island, and uh went into this class and I seen this thing, I think she called it a beam.
It was like look almost like a crucifix made out of wood that she would have the laser on one end and and and the film on the other.
And uh I ex, I says, Well, what is this?
And she goes, Well, that's what we're shooting our holograms on.
And I said, This, and I touched it and it didn't weigh that much, and it had a bunch of little air tubes underneath it, and we went in through the class and we actually produced a hologram.
So I was very excited with this information because I realized I didn't need a five-ton granite table anymore.
I didn't need a a two-ton sand table.
I said, This can be done.
This can be done.
And so it it kind of compressed it and reduced what what what I needed.
And from that class I was able to build like a little home studio, shoot some holograms.
That's how it began.
So it really goes back to my my uh tutorial class with Linda Law.
So Linda really helped me out.
You also have another book where it was holography for photographers as well, which I believe you took a lot of the math out and just presented it as a step-by-step process.
So if there's any photographers out there, maybe you'd want to tell them about that book as well.
Yes, exactly.
There was a lot of math in homemade holograms, a lot of technical stuff that if you're learning how to shoot a picture, you really don't need to know the mechanism of the camera.
You don't need to know about shutters, you don't need to know uh how the lenses work and how the focus optics work.
You could just point and shoot.
And with a little experience, you can shoot decent photography, different photographs.
So that was the approach I took with home made uh ph uh holography for photographers.
I left the math out, and I says, Okay, let's just shoot holograms and let's just shoot them as best we can with the smallest amount of equipment as possible and let it go on from there.
And that that was the the theory behind that book.
Your background in science and technology is known by so many people because of the articles that you've written over the years, all of the different books that you've put out, and you've got a company here as well, Images Company.
Is that correct?
The images companies that was uh tell us about the company.
Well, the uh the company caters to um I guess inquisitive minds.
We we we we do a lot of stuff with uh science and electronics and with holography, uh robotics.
Um it's just uh nuclear uh science, robonis, and just thinking speech recognition.
Um really have to visit the website and uh just see if it's just very diversified.
Give us the website address.
It's www.images.
So it's imagesco.com.
Any plans for the future with uh holography or where where do you see holography going for you and and as the field?
Well, I'm thinking about another book.
Uh if I do another book, it's really gonna be based towards the student uh for technology.
The holography hasn't expanded, hasn't hasn't really reached a mass market, never did.
We was always hoping for that to happen, that never did.
Well, I think well, yeah, you know, you could answer that better than I.
I think we were discussing that uh full color holography hasn't gotten out there.
Stereograms are still uh a little difficult to make and and still not full color.
I think that's that's part of it.
And and it's not easy.
I mean it still takes uh uh an amount of setup.
So but it it is something that artists can approach.
It's still like a craft uh that that they can get into and people can get into.
Do you plan on staying involved with holography?
Yeah, yeah.
I uh I don't know how active, you know, day to day, but sure, you know, I would never lose it.
I would always keep keep some of it around.
Well, you've built a laser in the past.
Tell us a little bit about the helium neon laser and how difficult that was.
That would be an interesting project for students or someone who even has their own lab to build their own helium neon laser.
How difficult was that for you?
At the time that I did it, oh, so many years ago, uh uh it was difficult because I didn't understand the uh physics behind the tube.
The tube is a negative resistance, which means that before the laser actually fires, it's a very high resistance.
Once it does fire, you got uh conduction through the ionized gas, so the resistance drops.
So um yeah, building a power supply was doable.
I could build it better today than I actually uh built in homemade holograms.
Uh, think homemade holograms used a car ignition coil, which you could still do it.
I think just basically changing uh one or two of the transistors uh in that circuit and it would be much more efficient.
As far as the tube, can you just go to one of the tube makers, the new on the neon sign tube makers, and have them make something for you?
No, I don't think so.
They can't.
The uh the the laser tubes themselves are very special and the you know the optics keeping the mirrors have to be perfectly aligned.
Um as far as using a neon sign transformer, probably would work, but you would probably burn out that tube like instantly.
I don't think that you really gotta watch the current going through the tube and the manufacturer's specifications as like two to three milliamps, and you really have to keep it there.
If you start pushing like 10 to 20 milliamps, which is what a neon sign transformer would do, that tube's gonna uh not last very long.
I'm sitting here with a uh hundred milliwatt green laser that I brought with me today.
I guess both of us have seen the technology change so much, and uh I was just wondering if you could give some of your thoughts on the new diode technologies and solid state technology and the fact that you can carry so much power around in your pocket.
Well, you know what?
This is what I want to play with.
This is something I haven't played with so far.
Uh and something that I do want to get into to see if these laser diodes can really perform equally to the gas lasers.
Uh so that's something I don't know.
Uh the the little bit that I did shoot with um laser diodes worked, but I didn't get the right beam spread where it was just like uh a small portion of the of the plate was illuminated, and the small portion that was illuminated worked, but the greater part of the the the film was not.
So so you know, so I needed a little work with that, but I I mean when I did it, I said, okay, it does work, and I had to work out the optics a little better.
But that again, that's many years ago, and I haven't really worked with it right now, and that's if I do anything, that's where I'm gonna be doing it.
You sell holography supplies to your company, right?
Right.
What are some of the things that you sell?
Well, basically I developed a technique of using magnets because I I wanted quick setups, quick knockdowns, and um using a metal table with magnets on it and having like the optics connected to the magnets made things very easy to align and get things set up and and shoot and break down.
So that's we sell the magnets, we sell metal tables, we sell that's what we sell.
Film and chemistry, they have to pretty much go somewhere else for that, I imagine.
Well, we sell the film.
Oh, you do.
What do you what do you have?
Um it's not the AFCA, it's uh it's um slavish.
It's not the BB plates that we break down into to smaller, so two two plate boxes.
Two and a half by two and a half.
Right, two and a half by two and a half film.
Um the the uh developing chemistry we get um very famous company.
Uh it's uh not into graft a photographer's formulary.
Photography's formulary we use their their setup for uh for the developing chemistry.
My my I myself I use D nineteen and I just use the bleach.
But uh so that's that's my thing.
If you can find D nineteen out there, that that's that's the way to go.
I've I've seen someone use D nineteen for reflection holograms, which it's not recommended to use, but they were great holograms.
Yeah, that's all I've used.
Yeah.
For all my reflection holograms is D nineteen, and I've I've gotten pretty good results with it.
One thing that people may want to try that that may not have uh done this is uh making life mask models.
Um where you make a life mask of a hand or somebody's face.
Then you could actually shoot that life mask and it's not pulse holography where you can actually take a a person's uh portrait, but uh it's a close facsimile and uh it's uh something that uh people should consider doing.
Would you paint that face or something or just do the life mask and use it as is?
Well, uh when you get the life mask, uh m what I usually do is that you have a 3D mold, and then what I would do is fill that mold in with uh a plaster or uh um there's another material, hydrocal, I think, which is a finer uh grain uh of material.
And then you have an actual three D uh bust or model of whatever you used, uh whether it be a hand to somebody's face, and shoot that.
So you're not actually shooting the mask, you're shooting which is a negative mold, you're shooting a positive mold made from the mask, right?
Yeah.
And where would someone get materials like that?
Any art supply store?
Yes.
Art supply stores and look at books because they have books on mask making and uh I think a lot in the theater industry, movie making they um have books on making masks and models that that would be very helpful.
Yeah I'm surprised we don't see more holograms of uh especially when you mention movie making I mean there's such incredible special effects with masks and lifelike type of appearances that you would think that you'd see some holograms around of that but we don't see anything.
I don't see any any holograms at all anymore.
You know what are your plans for uh the future with your company and uh yourself personally just keep going doing what I'm doing.
Um I am thinking about doing another book on holography but this will be a smaller book than a book uh simpler book uh just incorporating what I've learned over the last ten years, twenty years uh playing around with the technology and uh yeah trying to give it to the students now trying to aim aim to the high school and uh especially with the laser pointers now.
So if you can make decent holograms with laser pointers which is really made it easier to enter into the field.
But uh yeah.
Anything you'd like to tell the listeners that we haven't covered or that I haven't asked about?
No, no listen Frank is really great because he's been wanting to interview me for years and I'm saying well you know I really really don't have that much to say but uh yeah you've done it.
All right.
And we're gonna head out for breakfast.
So everyone take care and John thank you R very much for being on the show.
All right thanks.